[موسيقى]
إنها واحدة من تلك البرغر التي عندما تأكلها
تكون قذرة قليلاً ،
لكن مذاقها جيد جدًا
، برجر dm هو حقًا
نوع من البرجر المميز بالنسبة لنا ،
إنه برجر
الأهم من ذلك أمي  اعتدت أن أجعله
لي عندما كنت طفلاً وأنت تعرف أنه كان
شيئًا يجلب السعادة دائمًا
وكنت متحمسًا لأنه كان
ليلة برغر ولم أستطع الانتظار
حتى يحدث ذلك
[موسيقى]
أحد مطاعمي في لوس أنجلوس نحن
قررت وضع هذا البرجر
وحقق نجاحًا كبيرًا ، فأنا أعني أن
نيويورك تايمز أحببته ، لقد
أحبها ضيوفنا ، وقد حصل على هذه
السمعة باعتبارها البرجر المثالي ،
إنه بسيط للغاية ولكنه يعتمد على أنك
تعرف فترة من  في الوقت الذي كان كل شيء في
ذلك الوقت يدور حول بساطة
المكونات ، كانت المكونات هي
الأفضل ، لذلك نستخدم شيدر فيرمونت القديم
معها ، لدينا صلصة سرية ، خس
، بصل ، وكعكة بريوش جميلة ،
وهذا كل شيء ، وهذا يعود إلى
فطيرة اللحم.  نحن  ليرة لبنانية لدينا
وصفة سرية بكمية الدهون
التي نستخدمها فيها ، لذلك من المذهل تمامًا
أن نشوي البرغر ونضع الجبن على
نذوب نخب الجبن ونضع
البرجر فوق الخبز ثم
نمزج  الصلصة الخاصة بنا وسلطة السلو معًا
في تلك اللحظة بالذات ، ثم نتبل
فوق البرجر ونغلقه ونأكله
لقد كان الأمر بسيطًا للغاية ولكن
كان يجب أن يتم كل شيء في الوقت المناسب فقط
، فليس بالطماطم أو الخس الكلاسيكي
أو البصل  حتى لو كان باهظًا
حيث تضيف مكونات فاخرة ، فهو
مجرد تجربة فريدة من نوعها على برجر
لك